nous sommes une maladie qui infecte notre
planète de l'atmosphère à la
zone abyssale nous sommes pollués c'est un
fait connu le grand Garbage Patch
flottant dans le Pacifique est plus grand que plus
grand que le pays de France même
au fond de la fosse des Mariannes  nous
découvrons des nano plastiques nous ne pouvons
plus nous permettre le luxe de le faire à moitié
alors que nous nous forçons volontairement
au-delà du seuil de non-retour
parce qu'une espèce humaine nous avons besoin des
terriens pour survivre mais ne vous y trompez pas
la terre n'a pas besoin de nous
[  Musique]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui, je me tiens devant vous en tant que
représentant singulier de toutes les nations insulaires. Je suis
honoré de représenter ceux qui continuent
à se battre en tant que gardiens de cette planète. Nous,
les nations insulaires et toutes les
communautés côtières, sommes en première ligne dans cette
crise environnementale.  délégués, je vous demande
maintenant si nous sommes toujours unis pour cette
cause avez-vous l'intention d'honorer les
engagements pour une amélioration de l'homme meilleur
de l'humanité ou allez-vous continuer à rechercher
les profits à court terme au-dessus des
droits humains fondamentaux de nos enfants à vivre sur cette terre
tous  la terre, peu importe sa taille,
flotte sur l'océan comme un canoë au
milieu de la mer la planète n'est rien de
plus qu'une île flottant parmi un
océan d'étoiles la vie sur un navire flottant
a des ressources limitées cela nécessite des
pratiques de conservation strictes et soigneusement
planifiées  navigation pour assurer la survie, nous
devons travailler ensemble en tant que communauté mondiale
pour diriger au mieux notre canoë dans la bonne
direction
la direction de l'avenir sain et
abondant sur terre que nous appelons
chez nous,
veuillez nous rejoindre la voie des Samoa et un
engagement unifié pour protéger et guérir
la planète  est pour nous tous Aloha je suis
sur
toi